[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what's
making the headlines with the daily
miles consultant editor andrew pearce
and the daily mirrors associate editor
kev mcguire with us from now until just
before midnight so welcome to both of
you
as ever we'll start with the uh the
front pages the guardian then hearing
from union representatives warning that
recent and future rail strikes could
soon lead to a general strike if agree
if disagreements aren't resolved
that is also the main story for the r uk
general strike threat they say
shocking that's how the mirror describes
the possibility that household energy
bills could soon hit 500 pounds a month
the telegraph leads with a warning from
the uk's national security adviser that
china and the west could accidentally go
to nuclear war with each other as china
expands its nuclear arsenal
according to the metro the past month is
likely to be recorded as the driest july
since 1911.
the financial times reports that the u.s
central bank the federal reserve has
raised interest rates by three quarters
of a point for the second month running
the daily mail goes with the story of a
barrister who has won a landmark legal
battle
over her right to stand up to what the
paper calls trans extremists accused of
trying to wipe out women's rights
and the star shares its tips for
avoiding a drought some of which seem to
involve questionable hygiene
according to the paper uh well a
reminder that by scanning the qr code
you'll see on screen during the
programme you can check out the front
pages tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
um that is a map of
the fires around yosemite national park
but anyway uh tonight we're joined by
kevin mcguire and andrew pearce uh
welcome to both of you good to see you
let's start with those household energy
bills shall we you know some
extraordinary figures we see whole
wholesale gas prices back in the top of
the news agenda again i mean kevin has
anybody going to afford
3850 pounds you know nearly 500 pounds a
month it's incredible isn't it
no absolutely it would uh plunge more
than half of households into fuel
poverty which is calculated spending
more than a tenth of your income on gas
and electricity prices would be three
times what they were at the beginning of
the year and it's
why political parties uh running around
saying you can have this rebate you can
have that you can have a payment haven't
quite grasped the
the scale of the problem and and yes a
lot of it is uh
propelled fueled uh by what's happened
uh in ukraine with putin's invasion but
you can see how the whole cost of living
crisis now is around fuel and fuel bills
and it is the number one political issue
and i think parties are going to have to
think of really dramatic and drastic uh
answers and that that may include a
covert style emergency intervention and
take public ownership of the uh gas and
electricity companies these suppliers
and run them in the public interest
rather than leaving them as a
profit generating companies in the
private sector yeah i mean is that where
we're up to do you think andrew
government intervention to try and solve
this i mean we did some calculating 31
500 is the average household income uh
if if energy or fuel poverty counts as
you know ten percent of your earnings
going on energy then that leaves well
a monstrous proportion of people unable
to pay this bill properly
it'll be the biggest biggest cost of
living crisis ever uh in modern times
and
it will need really major solutions i
don't know what they're going to be
we've got to hope perhaps
that
russia's threats but i mean they're
restricting gas supplies i mean
lights are going to start going out all
over europe in particular where they're
so dependent on russian gas i don't know
what the answer's going to be but the
400 pounds every household is going to
get is barely going to touch the surface
is it if bills really do go
that high um it's it's shocking that's
the right word on the front page of the
mirror headline um and
who knows uh good help god help us
maybe it goes even higher putin is if he
is wielding his maximum power while he
can
uh and it's why we're gonna have to i
think start um doing more on nuclear
power we're gonna have to start
reopening uh our oil fields up in the
north sea uh because um we just we can't
go on like this
well the uh telegraph suggests that
britain will rely on more imported power
to help keep the lights on this winter
this according to the national grid
um which has issued its annual outlook
suggesting it expects to be able to draw
on undersea cables sending power from
the continent this winter but warned of
tight periods in early december even
with this support now they get the
the story towards the bottom of that
front page um european energy is the key
to keeping lights on this winter germany
is already deeply concerned as we saw
from our reporting earlier
um you know street lights not being
turned on in germany you know will will
the gas we need to import be available i
suppose is my question kevin
yeah well i love it that the brexit
support in daily telegraph is now
advocating european solutions and
looking to those countries it wants to
turn its back on uh to now save and bail
out britain but now we're going to be
absolutely dependent and
until
we generate all our electricity all our
power from renewables and nuclear we're
going to be
caught up and victims of changes in
international price and demand and that
european power which we will rely on
which the brexit telegraph is saying is
now going to keep the keep the lights on
well that's going to come at a price
it's not going to reduce bills because
there is a market here and we're going
to be
burned by by that market and
you know andrew's right about we're
going to have to uh get on uh with
nuclear i'm not so sure about
north sea and expanding in the future
but of course it all takes time it's not
now we're living here in 2022
building you get a power station you're
talking 10 12 15 20 years
we're were paying a price for for not
developing uh nuclear in in the in the
recent past we we have renewables and i
think it was one day last week that uh
renewables uh wind was generating more
than half the electricity used in the uk
admittedly was a warm day and it wasn't
it wasn't a winter demand
but it's where we have to go we have to
go green and nukes it's the only way but
it will take time it's going to be
terrible in the short term and it's how
do you get over that with protecting
households
uh but can you do it without a major
intervention and taking over the the
power sector and running running it as a
public service rather than a
profit generating uh private system
and meanwhile i think i think i'm sorry
well i think i was going to say i think
what we'll do if you we all we're kevin
and i are old enough to remember the
three-day week under ted heath when we
simply didn't there was the power cuts
but i suspect as with as you we're going
to see in the year across the european
union where there's appeals for
consumption to be reduced by 15
i think we're going to have to do that
in britain as we get closer to the
winter but there will just have to be a
way of reducing how much power we're
using because families won't be able to
pay for it
to some extent households will do that
because bills go up and people will be
more
likely your flights turn down uh
thermometers and that can create
problems uh for some people if they are
literally choosing between eating and
hitting other people can't do it if
you're you're disabled or elderly or
have a medical condition you may require
a really warm home you can't just put on
another
jumper but um you know a lot of it a lot
of industry it just just requires power
that that is it it needs it they can't
they can't just switch it to switch it
off so we are in a in a in a in a bind
and in one way if you're if you're
puting in the kremlin and you're facing
sanctions over your unprovoked uh
invasion of ukraine of course you're
going to use power as a
as a weapon we sanction him he's going
to try and sanction us back it's the
it's the way of the world and for
instance the saudis johnson has been
over biden's been over
it's a horrible uh evil regime but they
they've so far
resisted calls to turn on the taps and
produce more
more fuel they want their their position
of power too so
in britain where we are where
we're actually paying a price for not
going for more renewables and more nukes
earlier
well and increasingly consumer goods
companies and retailers acknowledging
they can no longer absorb uh you know
the rising costs um we've seen a whole
list of them haven't we in the last few
weeks uh now we add the cheeseburger uh
rising by 20p at mcdonald's andrew
yeah and i i it's just staggering i mean
i don't eat mcdonald's i can't bear the
stuff but um if they've not gone up for
14 years which is a staggering uh uh
admission i didn't i just who would have
known that
um but it's a sign uh foodstuffs are it
gone up in price it's the cost of uh
deliveries uh fuel to get the stuff to
the donald's restaurants and that's a
pretty big rise although i suppose one
benefit is it might improve the nation's
health because i don't think mcdonald's
burgers are ever very good for us are
they well the problem is the
cheeseburger is symbol of all the other
things that are also rising presumably
the lettuce is also going the same way
everywhere
let's look at interest rates shall we
the fed uh front page of the financial
times federalist rates by 0.75 points i
mean that's a whopper compared to what
we've been saying for the second month
in a row and the battle detain inflation
is something that we're seeing all you
know in every nation almost aren't we
kevin
yeah i like you used to the word whopper
which of course is a burger king product
arrival
yeah but that's uh you know that 0.75
increases on the on top of the 0.5
increase earlier we're going back to the
uh you know the early 1980s 1981 when
inflation was high and interest rates
soared as uh
as a result but
right raising interest rates can perhaps
curb inflation but then they create in
their own problems where people have got
loans and mortgages and they can't pay
them and employment can go up as as a
result but
it's it's a kind of reminder that the
the problems in the uk and uh are not
unique they're around europe and around
the world
but it is why in some ways are we
suffering more than other countries
because for instance next year the oecd
predicts there will be zero economic
growth in the uk only russia which is
sanctioned
will
have a worse performance that'll be
negative but other other countries into
france germany at least spain
uh japan canada us other economies will
do better than ours why are we doing so
badly but at the same time i i
acknowledge that the ft there reporting
interest rate school in the us
we're not alone in that way we're going
through a turbulent period but why in
some ways are we doing worse in other
countries that's a question who backed a
government that's been in power for 12
years where's andrew uh need to answer
well
the thing is i mean we yeah well the
projection is we might we we might be
the lowest the worst but these
projections are often wrong but the fact
is the whole world economy is groaning
it's under strain and although we might
be worse in g7 but the rest aren't doing
much better kevin and he knows that and
uh and
but while we do have one advantage we
don't have the huge unemployment which
we had in the early 1980s when we had
this problem with rising interest rates
and inflation we have virtually got full
employment
okay
that's partly because one-fifth of the
workforce has opted out stop stop
time i've got drought to talk about
the news that britain could be set for
its driest july since 1911
discussing that after the break
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now andrew pearce and
kevin mcguire welcome back to both of
you a number of newspapers leading on
this not least the i andrew you start um
a uk general strike possibility uh it
seems that seems the words of liz trust
has that aggravated the unions who are
already inflamed by pay rises and uh
changes
she's doing the iron lady bit you
remember mrs thatcher one of her great
uh strengths and
successes i would say was her curbing of
the unions in the 1980s that liz trust
wants to bring in something that boris
johnson promised by the way in the 2019
manifesto effectively a minimum service
agreement so that
if for essential infrastructure like the
railways there has to be a minimum
service for instance we think it could
be
30 or 35
well today there was 20 train service
running that's infuriated the tuc it's
infuriated the rail unions and they're
talking about a general strike well i
think quite a lot of the public will
support it not least because if you go
to spain if you go to france go to
germany to go to italy they have just
that minimum service agreements for
essential infrastructure like rail
services quick comment kevin
yeah look the transport secretary grant
shaps has refused to meet the trade
unions the the government is
wanting these strikes for political
purposes but i think i think andrew's
mistaken on this and i think there's a
lot of sympathy for people who stand up
we've just discussed the cost of living
crisis
the reason people are going on strike is
they're worried about their living
standards and their jobs the government
resolves that problem there won't be any
strikes so the blame here has to be with
the government it's not in control of
all events because of what's happening
in the world i understand that and grasp
that but just to bring in more shackles
on trade unions is fundamentally wrong
it's unprincipled and it won't resolve
the core problem in these disputes
and the root of that as we discussed
earlier is energy the cost of it how to
pay for it how to source it even which
takes us to the other issue which is the
lack of water in this country now or
large parts of it andrew and we're
looking at the driest july since 1911
and the metro is suggesting in five days
it might be all
records well in 1911 i looked it up uh
of course in those days people didn't
have refrigerators so food was good food
was going off there was disease
pestilence asphalt was melting
temperatures then were 98 degrees and it
had been a dry year um but this
potentially could be much worse of
course because we use a lot more water
now not least in the industrial process
so we're in a very difficult position i
can remember the standpipes in swindon
where i lived in 1976. it wasn't great
it just but you do feel like we're going
back to that
yeah encouraged you to grow your own
can't keep your carrots alive can you
that's the thing can't have a shower
kevin never does anyway
[Music]
all you can say though uh anna is those
who say in this crisis cut investment in
renewable energy and tackling climate
change look we've got we got to do it
otherwise we're going to have major and
bigger problems down the line we've got
we've got a stick
to green in the economy and we'll win in
the long run yeah was that was that a
message just to the two vying to be
prime minister i think probably it was
anyway final quick thought 30 seconds on
the metro uh the little lion test uh and
other coverage of the uh extraordinary
women's football team andrew
well they're playing you couldn't make
it up they're going to play and they're
going to play germany aren't they in the
final he's double checking
yeah the old enemy um come on england
come on you lionesses i haven't watched
any of it yet okay so i will watch the
final